[Music]
good morning Hank it's the day before
Thanksgiving it's also the 102nd
anniversary of the publication of Albert
Einstein's famous paper does the inertia
of a body depend upon its energy content
of course the answer to that question
was heck yes it does
Hank someday I'd like to write an
analogous paper with a similar
conclusion called
does the awesomeness of a body depend
upon its nerd content I would use this
paper to prove through the magic of
physics that the accumulation of
knowledge increases the overall
worldwide level of Awesome except for
when you're accumulating knowledge about
Britney Spears that actually cuts
awesome levels in a related story boy am
i inert hank speaking of nerdiness it
occurs to me that over the course of
this year-long project i've talked a lot
about what a nerd i am and what a
nerdfighter I am and how awesome it is
to be a nerd and everything and yet that
whole time I've had glasses that aren't
very nerdy I mean I understand that
glasses are inherently nerdy but what
I'm saying is that my glasses aren't
particularly nerdy problem solved these
are so nerdy I like them so Hank as you
hinted at in your video yesterday our
family has a long and storied tradition
of always saying what we're grateful for
when we gather around the Thanksgiving
table now obviously we're not all going
to be together this year for
Thanksgiving because you're in snowy
Missoula and I'm in weirdly warm
Indianapolis nonetheless I'd like to
share some of what I'm grateful for
first I'm thankful to you for the
amazing year that we've had getting to
know each other as grownup siblings now
I realized that there's something a
little bit ironic about calling you and
myself a grown-up when we spent a lot of
the year putting stuff on our heads and
singing about Harry Potter but still I'm
thankful that it's snowing in Missoula
Montana right now because with all this
warm weather in Indianapolis I was
beginning to believe that maybe it would
never snow anywhere at any time for the
rest of human history also this year I'm
particularly thankful to YouTube for
giving the world a free and easy way for
Luddites like me to communicate visually
I'm thankful that I get to write the
books I want to write when I want to
write them for the people I want to
write them for I'm thankful that I have
two functioning eyes three nerdfighter
t-shirts and one beautiful Yeti I'm
thankful that you're such a good
songwriter and finally Hank I'm thankful
for the nerd
I mean their collective awesome really
has changed our lives I'm so much more
optimistic than I used to be Hank
because I've seen so many of the good
things that can happen when people come
together I find myself thinking that
Faulkner was right when he declined to
accept the end of man saying it is easy
enough to say that man is immortal
because he will endure that when the
last ding dong of doom has claimed and
faded from the last worthless rock
hanging tideless in the last red and
dying evening that even then there will
still be one more sound that of his puny
inexhaustible voice still talking I
refuse to accept this I believe that man
will not merely in dear he will prevail
he is immortal not because he alone
among creatures has an inexhaustible
voice but because he has a soul a spirit
capable of compassion and sacrifice and
endurance
oh also I'm thankful for Faulkner that
guy knew his way around his sentence
there's something pretty amazing about
being able to believe that Hank and
that's a gift that nerdfighters have
given me so thanks Hank nerdfighters
what are you grateful for nerdfighters
your internet-only scavenger hunt clue
for the day is the last word of Looking
for Alaska